the Joe Rogan experience so one of me
ask you a question a couple of weeks ago
Disney Plus permit Oh two days later
people drawing fits what do you want
them to do to go back and take all this
[ __ ] out is all movies well that's a
good question what do you do you ever go
to Disneyland you know that one ride
what is it a Splash Mountain yes that
Splash Mountain ride is based on a movie
that you can't even watch anymore there
it was a really racist movie
well Disney was racist was he not I
don't know this Splash Mountain was
voices this is it's called the song of
the south that was the movie and from
what year is that Jamie six 1946 but
people were different animals back dog
we're not even the same species what
about the lady who sang the national
anthem at the Yankees somebody found out
that 30 years before that you didn't
know about that
no you gotta look this up she sang songs
that were like totally racist like
spooky get out of town like [ __ ] like
this please look it up right nationally
right now so two ball fields took her
version of the national anthem now you
had to read this [ __ ] she was here
cements god Bless America out at Yankee
Stadium over racist song listen to the
song she said whose kids I'm [ __ ] fat
chick from 19 2013 19 31 song
yeah that's why [ __ ] were born wait a
minute she sang this in 1931 yeah how
old is this [ __ ] is he still alive
it's like the recording of God Bless
America from back then that they used to
just play during right she sang that but
when did she when she recorded 1937 but
when did she sing the national anthem no
no it's the god Bless America is what
they're talking about here okay well
when did she sing god bless america
1929 1930 something I don't know back
then but she also song sang a song
called that's why [ __ ] a boy I was
confused I was thinking you were saying
that she sang it at the lyric someone
she pick cotton
someone had to pick the corn someone had
this be a slave and somebody had this
thing that's why [ __ ] were born oh
that you know I mean all these things
the song which has been called a
satirical take on racism was a big hit
for Smith and also was recorded by a
Paul Robeson hmm hmm so she wrote and
sang god Bless America so the version
that you would hear like God she sang it
so that recorded it so the version that
you would hear would be back then right
so yeah see that's a that's why she gets
weird you know there's been a lot of
great people over the years that have
had some horrible ideas oh so you have
to wonder like like if we just cut out
the guy I mean how many people different
people who have invented incredible
things that we use all the time
we're also really shitty human beings
[Applause]